hello and welcome i'm james murphy and
in this video we're going to crack some
passwords
thanks to this video's sponsor anvil a
browser-based
full stack development platform allowing
you to make web apps with nothing but
python
more about anvil at the end of the video
sorry to disappoint any wannabe hackers
in the crowd
but this is not going to be a hacking
tutorial
after watching this video you're not
going to be able to just go out and hack
your friends or your colleagues or
government databases
what you are going to get from this
video is a quick dip into the deep end
what are some of the things that make it
so incredibly difficult
to write secure software in my opinion
the biggest difference between the way
that code is modeled in the theoretical
world
and how it actually is in the real world
is the amount of time
that code takes to execute well in the
real world
there's an entire class of attacks that
exploit
the physical amount of time that an
algorithm took to execute
these are called timing attacks that's
what we're going to investigate in this
video
we'll be able to crack a password that's
20 characters long
in no time okay so let's get started
what's the system that we're going to
hack in this video
well i have a server which is really
just a function
and all this does is i pass in a user
and my guest for the password
and it's going to look up the password
in the database which is actually just a
dictionary up here
and after it looks it up in the database
all it does is tell you
whether or not your guess was equal to
the actual password
in this video we're going to be taking
the attacker's perspective so we don't
get to see the check password function
check password is just a black box we
plug in the username
and the guess and we either get you got
it correct or you didn't
we don't get to see anything else i know
this is silly
check password is just a function in the
same file this is totally ridiculous
but think about check password as
actually going out to the internet and
trying to log into a server
this is a pretty bad server because it's
going to allow us to make many many many
guesses and it's not going to ban us
for spamming or anything like that too
many wrong attempts but
i think it gets the point across okay
let's get to cracking
at first glance it might seem completely
hopeless
passwords can be extremely long 30
characters or more
and all we're getting out of this is is
the password correct or not
if we get even a single bit wrong then
we basically gain no information
right well not completely the whole
theme of this video is that
we do get one extra piece of information
that the server didn't tell us about
we can measure how much time it took to
respond
if we suspected that the server was
using a bad implementation like this
just equality checking the actual
password against the guess
which by the way the server shouldn't
even store your actual password
then we might be able to exploit
something about how long it takes to
compute the answer
when the guess is closer to correct
in pretty much every programming
language the first thing that happens
when you compare two strings for
equality
is it checks to see if their lengths are
the same if the lengths are different
then you can pretty quickly return false
so if we query the server with a guess
if the length of the password is wrong
then the server will respond
faster let's see if we can use that to
crack the length
of this password okay here's what we'll
do
we'll take the user and the maximum
possible length that we think the
password could be
then we'll just loop over the different
lengths and use the timeit.repeat method
to time how long each password attempt
takes
the statement that we're timing is this
check password of the user and a guess
x where here the user is inputted as
whatever
the argument was and x is a random
string
generated by this function repeat
returns a list and we just take the
fastest time from that list to use as
the server response time
we take the fastest time here because
the server might have just lagged for
some unknown reason
and we don't want that to slow down our
timing we want to measure its
performance assuming it didn't lag at
all
to recap all i do is guess passwords of
a bunch of different lengths
and then return the length that takes
the longest to respond
and here's what we see when we run it
passwords that were randomly guessed of
length 20
took a little bit longer than the rest
notice that
the second longest choice was 93 percent
as fast and what you know the length of
the actual password is 20
and this is not a fluke if i change the
length of the string so that now it's
length 19 instead of 20 and run the
program again
now we see that the most likely length
is 19.
of course if you have other things on
your machine going on that are affecting
the timing like
recording video then it's going to make
it a lot less likely to give you the
right answer
when i ran it again i got that 25 is the
most likely length which is not correct
but 19 was still in the top three so
if you were a real hacker trying to do a
real timing attack
you would probably be doing this on a
dedicated machine that doesn't have lots
of random programs
executing at the same time that might
mess up the timing
okay finding out the length of the
password is one thing but guessing the
actual password is something entirely
different
so can the timing attack do that as well
well if the implementation was one of
these simple equality checks then yes
because here's what an equality check
for strings looks like under the hood
as we mentioned before first it does a
length check and that's what we use to
crack the length of the password
but after it does the length check it
goes character by character
and if any of them are not equal then it
will return
immediately because string comparison
will return early if the password
is incorrect at an earlier position
again we find that
the more correct the password is the
longer the server will take to respond
this is exactly the same thing that we
can use to exploit as with the length
so here's the code that i came up with
in order to crack a password using a
timing attack
given that you've already cracked the
length of the password it's similar to
cracking the length itself
except we have to go position by
position and get each character right in
turn
we start with just a completely random
guess of the correct length
we don't know how much of the password
that we've guessed so far is correct
so we're just going to repeatedly loop
over the entire string
try to get the first character correct
then the second then the third and so on
until the end
and then start back at the beginning
we'll just keep repeating until we get
the right password
for each position in the password we try
every possible character
that can be in the password and then we
see what happens when we put that
character in that position
we'll time how long it takes for our new
guess we'll time how long it takes for
our old guess
and then whichever one took more time we
keep as the
old guess for the next iteration notice
that by random chance we could have a
more correct guess get replaced with a
less correct guess
i'm sure that we'll see that happen when
we actually run it but nevertheless the
more correct guess
is more likely to take longer and so
eventually we will build up the correct
password
here we check to see if our new guess is
the correct password and if it is
then we're done we return otherwise what
we do is we take the one that took
longer and use that as the guess for the
next iteration
and that's it all we have to do now is
try it
so first we will crack the length of the
password and then use that length
pass it into the cracked password
function and see how long it takes to
find the actual password
all right let's just see how well it
[Music]
does
so just on the first iteration it's
gotten a lot of the characters right
already let's see if it can finish off
the last few in the next one
[Music]
and there you go it finished password
cracked subscribe to encoding
so there you have it we just cracked a
password that was 20 characters long
using nothing but timing information
this was just
one example of one timing attack and
timing attacks themselves are just a
single class of examples
in a huge sea of things that you can
mess up
and if you mess up anything then you're
going to get yourself hacked
don't trust the security of your
customer data or of your web app in
general
to something that's not extremely well
tested and proven
and speaking of writing web apps if
you're interested in that kind of thing
be sure to stick around and hear about
our sponsor anvil
that's all i've got for now see you in
the next one anvil has everything you
need to develop and deploy
a web app written completely in python
including the front end so no javascript
or html required
and it's free to try create your user
interface by dragging and dropping
components
anvil's web-based ide allows you to
develop in your browser
no need to install anything you can use
anvil's built-in database and let anvil
handle the tricky parts like user
authentication
when you're ready deploy your app to the
cloud with a single click
check out the link in the description to
get started with anvil today